welcome back let's do a couple more
angle game problems and and hopefully
this will make you an angle game expert
so let's start I have the star drawn
again and let's say we know the
following angles we know this angle
right here is 41 degrees 41 degrees we
know this angle here is 113 degrees 13
degrees we know this angle here is 101
degrees
101 and what we need to figure out this
is the goal of this angle game we want
to figure out what this angle is and
like always I encourage you to try it on
your own pause the video and then you
know just try to work it through and if
you get stuck then play the video again
and and hopefully I'll have a solution
for you so pause right now
but otherwise let me explain how to do
this so let's see we know this this and
this we're going to figure out this
angle how can we figure out this angle
what are possible strategies well if we
knew this angle here we could say
they're supplementary that angle seems
like a hard angle to figure out too
because it's not a part of any triangles
but this angle is a part of of this
triangle right here right so if we were
able to figure out this angle and this
angle these green angles if we're able
to figure out these green angles then we
could figure out this brown angle which
is the goal of this angle game so this
could also be a good time to follow us
because I just gave you a hint
but let's see this green angle well it's
it's supplementary to this angle right
here so that means it adds up to 180
degrees and that's clear because it's on
kind of the same line so this is 101
degrees and this is going to be 79
degrees right because it adds up to 180
degrees that's 79 now how can we figure
out this angle well it's kind of left by
itself out in the corner of some place
so you know we could see if it's part of
any triangles well we already said it's
part of this triangle but that doesn't
help us because we don't know this angle
and that's actually our goal
what other triangles is it a part of
what's a part of this triangle right
here
that's why I like the star problem
because it has all these triangles in it
that might not be obvious to you the
first time you look at it but more you
look at you see all these triangles so
it's part of this triangle and it's also
part of this triangle and I'm going to
draw this triangle in another color
because I think it'll be clear to you
that this is a useful triangle to see
that it's a part of it's part of this
triangle
there you go so we have that triangle so
do we know two of the angles of that
triangle well sure we know this angle
and we know this angle so we know that
this angle plus 113 plus 41 is going to
equal 180 degrees because they're the
three angles of a triangle so let's let
me call this I don't know G for green a
whoops I haven't switched out of my so
let's call this G for green so we know G
plus 113 degrees 113 that's this one
right here plus 41 41 remember we're
looking at this triangle that's hardest
part just keeping track of which
triangle we're looking at is going to
equal 180 degrees G Plus what is this
154 all right 40 50 or 154 is equal to
hundred eighty degrees that's always
where I mess up on the addition and so G
is equal to what it says 26 degrees
right because I just subtract 154 from
both sides 26 degrees so we're almost
there
so we figured out G we know this green
angle we just have to figure out this
and they're all part of this triangle
the small one right here this small
triangle so our goal which is let's call
this X X plus G which is 26 degrees
which just figure that out 26 Plus this
angle 79 all right we figured that out
because it was supplementary to this
angle it's going to equal 180 degrees so
X plus what is this 105 is equal to 180
so X is equal to 75 degrees if I did my
addition and subtraction correctly so X
is equal to 75 degrees and then we are
done let's do another one of these
problems and these problems were all
generated on the Khan Academy website
dynamically by the computer whoever
wrote this this software must must
genius anyway back to the problems clear
inverted colors let me draw some more
this is going to be a pretty
straightforward drawing it's pretty much
just two triangles next to each other
like that let me draw another line it
goes like that line it goes like that
and I think I am done my drawing there
you go I am done my drawing so let's see
what do we know about this triangle and
what do we need to figure out so I'm
going to tell you that this angle here
this big angle here is 86 degrees 86
degrees we also know that this angle
here is 28 degrees 28 degrees and we
also know that this angle here is 122
degrees and our goal our mission in this
round is to figure out what this angle
is and maybe we can do it we do it in a
good color maybe we can do it in a
couple of different ways so one thing we
could do is we could figure out what if
we could figure out what this angle is
then we could just subtract this green
angle from 86 and we would get our
answer well this angle is easy right
because we know two angles of this
triangle so we could figure that out
let's just call this item let's call
this Y so Y plus 120 222 plus 28 degrees
it's going to equal 180 so Y Plus this
150 is equal to 180 so Y is equal to 30
degrees right so this is equal to 30
degrees it's equal 30 degrees so this is
30 degrees and this big angle here is 86
so our goal let's call that X X so X is
going to just be equal to the big angle
86
- this angle we just figured out - 30 so
X is going to be equal to 50 degrees
done that was a pretty straightforward
problem let's see if we could figure
that out any other way well we could say
instead of doing it that way let's
forget like we just solved it that way
we could say this angle here is
supplementary to this 122 degree angle
right so it has to add up to 180 so this
plus 122 is 180 so what does that make
this it makes this 50 58 degrees right
this Plus this is going to be 180 so we
figured out this if we could figure out
this that we could use this triangle how
do we figure out this angle well we
could look at this big triangle here big
triangle here and we know this side
right we know this side we could figure
out this let's call this Z so we know
that Z Plus this angle plus 28 plus this
big angle plus 86 is equal to 180 so Z
plus what is this 106 114 is equal to
180 so Z is equal to what is this 66
degrees I don't know if I'm doing my
math correctly but let's just hope Z is
equal to 66 so this is so Z is 66 this
angle is 58 and now we can use this
triangle here to figure out what this
angle is our X so X plus 66 plus 58 is
equal to 180
so I already think I might have made a
mistake someplace in the Edition so this
time around I get X is equal to let's
see 66 was 58 is 110 plus 14 is 180
minus 124 so now I got it equal to
is equal to 56 degrees oh great I
actually got the right answer I was
looking at this I thought it was 50 but
this was 56 right 86 minus 30 so X is
equal to 56 degrees again so we did two
different ways so that's what I wanted
to show you there's actually not a right
answer as long as you kind of get there
eventually and we solved it two
different ways and I did all my addition
subtraction correctly and and you get
the exact same answer so hopefully
you'll you find the angle game fun and
you'll be playing this with your friends
I'll see you later